should we see if standby mine is there
i can't hear him so maybe he's not there
but
let's check one more time for stand by
me man
if he's not there like
i just hope that he's there basically
he's not here man
stand by me man he's not here
i think the numbers i think the
statistics do show that homelessness is
increasing differently especially under
the conservative government with
austerity and stuff like that
um
you know i'm i'm wary that i'm not an
expert and it is increasing but i think
the thing to that i would like to sort
of emphasize on that is that
homelessness is the tip of the eye of
the iceberg you know
people who are literally living on the
streets but there's a lot of people who
are homestyle not living on the streets
that are like living on friends
couches or living in cars or like you
know
you know just bouncing with different
family members don't really have a
stable permanent home
um
you know and then there's a lot of
people one step above that who are like
have a home but are just struggling to
make the rent i was struggling to make
the movie you're struggling to pay the
bills you know so um when homelessness
increases you can guarantee the number
of people who don't have a home and are
bouncing around increases and on people
who have a home buyer it's not secure
increases you know what i mean and those
are the big things which we're seeing
more and more and we will see more and
more if we don't do anything
unfortunately that's another pessimistic
message so i guess i should add on top
of that that look if we fix wealth
inequality we can reverse this but only
if we fix wealth inequality um
so like there's like there's two sides
of the message one is like if we don't
do anything things will get worse yeah
that's a message people don't want
to hear that but it's true and i'm not
just saying that i've been better on it
for 10 years and i've been right for 10
years
but if we do understand that then we can
fix it and then the scope that we have
for improving our economy is enormous
and what that means is
you can make good wages on a regular job
you know what i mean
or like you know my sister works in the
theater and she works so hard and she
just scripts to make the bills sometimes
you know i mean at the moment we live in
a world where these kind of artistic
creative jobs are basically not options
for people from poor backgrounds
we could move to a world where you could
do a job anything that you love even if
you're from a poor background and yeah
maybe you won't be rich but you you can
have you can have a good secure life you
know what i mean um
these are these were possible 50 years
ago these things you know what i mean
um so they're possible now but we need
to fix wealth inequality that's so we
have to do that and to do that we need
to build a movement and get people
understanding
how important it is
i mean you can go to university but can
you actually get a job that makes any
money afterwards you know what i mean
you know increasingly
like even people who
go to a good university and get a good
degree
and even work in a professional industry
are finding
that first of all these professional
industries they work you like dogs so
these guys are working 100 hour weeks
and then you know maybe they can make 50
60 grand a year which is great you know
for a young person much higher than
average salary but if you come from the
wrong kind of family even that you're
gonna have to really save and save and
save and save every year before you can
get a property you know what i mean and
these are the people who went to the
best universities and got the best jobs
you know i mean so what about the people
that went you know just to ordinary
universities you've got ordinary jobs
that is what most people are going to do
you know what i mean ordinary graduate
jobs you know so
i don't think you can really like put
your hand up and say we're succeeding as
a country because we're sending kids to
university if those kids are not able to
get financial security it reaches a
point where
in the end you need to go to university
to even compete in the job market so
then you've got like whatever 30 40 50
grand of debt you know maybe more if you
do a postgrad degree 100 grand of debt
and you still can't pay like you still
can't save much money you know what i
mean so the end result is
all we've done is forced people to stay
in education for an extra three years or
five years or eight years
pick up 100 grand of debt
and then
they would be even worse off than they
would have been 50 years ago you know
like i said my dad didn't go uni worked
in the post office 35 years
and he was never rich but paid off the
mortgage on their small house and he's
got a decent pension
there are people nowadays with advanced
graduate degrees that will not get the
same level of financial security that my
dad got working in the post office
that's crazy right that shouldn't be
happening you know i mean
and i don't want to limit what i'm
talking about to just people with
degrees you know because the reality is
you know if that's the people with
degrees what about the people who don't
have degrees you know i mean they're
probably making on average even less
money you know it's just like we're
squeezing ordinary people so hard just
just for what just so we can
just so we can send jeff bezos into
space again you know i mean like
it's mad um
but
yeah hopefully hopefully people will
realize and you know the channel will
grow and um
what i really want is for people to pick
up the message and share it themselves
because there's only so much you and me
can do but other people start picking up
the message sharing these videos sharing
my website economics.org if people want
to know more
then
the idea can spread itself you know and
it's not complicated idea
if you want to fix the economy
in terms of ordinary people's lives you
have to do something about off
inequality you do and that's
we can do that but only if we have
enough people supporting it politically
i mean moving on from that i guess
while you're looking very much like
nigel
i was drinking the pint before he said
we're gonna do the shooting by the way
it's not like i'm not trying to be nigel
farage
i mean there's talk in america at the
moment about some of these policies
are they the type of thing you're
talking about and why aren't politicians
here in this country talking about the
same thing interesting in it like
there's talk there there's a few
different things like global minimum
corporate tax yeah that's a good idea um
the wealth tax for super wealthy people
obviously that's like the most
interesting one
there was a lot of talk about that when
biden got in and i was telling everybody
look
the policy is a good policy
but come to me when it's enacted you
know what i mean because i know how it
works like
people want this so the politicians
pitch it and then when they get into
power
you know there's a lot of powerful
people that don't want it so they pull
the strings where they can and they get
a few politicians to vote against it and
it doesn't pass and that's exactly what
happened in the u.s you know what i mean
like it's very easy to make promises
but
it's not so easy to deliver you know i
mean so
you know i think personally a lot of
these politicians if they're not very
wealthy themselves they're influenced by
very wealthy people
um and that's why like
we
we just as ordinary people we have to be
switched on politically and we have to
be also
really clear and consistent in what we
demand we need to say we demand a
decrease in wealth inequality
a decrease in wealth inequality and an
increase in the holding of wealth by
ordinary people how much does the person
in the middle hold that they need to be
holding more year after year we cannot
accept the rich holding more and
ordinary people holding us we cannot
accept that we need to demand the
decreasing off inequality and um the
politicians i know what they do they say
yeah we'll do it we'll do it we'll do it
then they go on the back they bring in a
taxi stick a load of loopholes in it you
know what i mean um
but that's them trying to like pull the
wool over our eyes
and um
we we just need to say no did you
decrease wealth inequality that's the
one thing measure it by that one the
arctic did you decrease wealth
inequality are ordinary people owning
a bigger share of the property market
with smaller mortgages
or are they owning fewer houses with
bigger mortgages you know what i mean
measure it on our ordinary people
getting richer in terms of wealth or not
we have to demand that we have to demand
that
um
i know you know they'll follow us off
and they'll follow us off and we have to
keep demanding it and we have to vote on
it we have to say we're not going to
vote for you unless you do it we're
going to vote you out unless you do it
you're going to vote a new party in you
know what i mean and we just need to
keep saying that same thing and i know
like you know the voting system in this
country is a bit ridiculous it's like a
two-party system but you know
tell the party in government if you
don't fix wealth inequality we will not
vote for you you know what i mean and if
the other party doesn't do it then don't
vote for them either you know you just
need to keep forcing it you know and i
think that brexit is a good example the
two main parties didn't want it but
people demanded they wanted to do it
and eventually they got it and that
would be an easier fight because a lot
of super rich people and some newspapers
were happy with brexit
accepted it and mostly rich people will
not accept a
higher taxes on the world fee
but it's more important for ordinary
people so we need to push harder and um
yeah just like it is the one thing that
we need to make things better and we
need to just demand it consistently
make wealth more equal reduce wealth
inequality and you know we need to just
consistently judge governments by them
they're going to keep like throwing
nonsense at us like oh we're reducing
immigration and we're getting rid of
asylum seekers and we're going to be
tough on drugs you know i mean
screw all that
are you giving follow the money are you
giving money and assets back to ordinary
people or are you giving money and
assets from ordinary people to the rich
don't let them like blind you with all
of these like cultural stuff
follow the money because right now
they're just telling you oh it's good
because we're keeping the polish people
out and they're taking your houses
you know what i mean follow the money
demand the money back demand that wealth
becomes
that that is how
we achieve change
but poorer families will be forced to
lose almost all of the assets
including their home
we have a tax system which is very
efficient attacking ordinary working
people but very inefficient attacks in
the super rich
[Music]